bonjour à toutes et à tous avec 6 juin à
guillaume larrivé on est ravis de vous
accueillir pour ce point presse nous
allons commencer avec quelques éléments
d'agenda le président nicolas sarkozy se
rendra les 26 et 27 avril en région
provence alpes côte d'azur plus
particulièrement dans les départements
des alpes maritimes du var et des
bouches du rhône mardi qui sera à nice
le matin l'après midi il sera à toulon
mercredi il sera le matin à marseille et
l'après-midi à aix en provence
nous souhaitons revenir sur les second
tour des élections législatives
partielles qui s'est déroulé hier ainsi
que sur le second tour de l'élection
cantonale qui s'est déroulé également à
saint mihiel dans le département de la
meuse
hier nous notons la très forte
progression du candidat les républicains
mathieu anne rocky ci est arrivé second
a fait un score qu'il faut absolument
noter au regard du résultat de monsieur
ayrault qui était le dernier titulaire
de cette circonscription monsieur
ayrault avait été élu en 2012 avec 59%
des voix au premier tour on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le parti socialiste
n'arrive même pas au second tour à
atteindre ce niveau et que aujourd'hui
la gauche sur cette circonscription qui
est clairement ancré très à gauche
depuis très longtemps et au niveau de
1993 soit l'année où la gauche a fait
son plus mauvais score et a engrangé le
plus petit nombre de députés à
l'assemblée nationale
tout cela est plutôt encourageant pour
l'avenir et nous disons à mathieu anne
rockin ne faut pas évidemment se
décourager bien au contraire il faut
persévérer nous sommes certains que
l'année prochaine il a devant lui la
possibilité d'emporter cette
circonscription
autre élément de satisfaction
effectivement il y avait un canton dans
la région grand est qui était
au front national dans la commune de
saint mihiel et suite à une invalidation
ce canton a été remportée hier par les
candidats de lui des ics et soutenues
par les républicains et nous sommes
ravis aujourd'hui de pouvoir dire que
dans la région grand est
plus aucun département n'a un canton
détenu par le fonds national
alors nous avons dans l'actualité de ce
jour une annonce faite par un certain
nombre de ministres du gouvernement
qu'il intitule opération reconquête
reconquête 2017
c'est sur le fun qui est à l'initiative
de cette opération qu'il intitule
lui-même et aux la gauche
nous ferons pas insultes d'aller sur
blanche neige et les sept nains ce
n'était pas l'objectif de notre point
presse par contre puisque il va y avoir
un certain nombre de ministres puisque
je crois que deux tiers du gouvernement
seront présents à cette manifestation
bien nous nous avons aussi un héros a
adressé aujourd'hui ses ministres pour
leur demander un certain nombre de
réponses et ceo se décline en plusieurs
éléments et au stéphane le foll stéphane
le foll est à l'initiative de cette
manifestation et jean michel baylet il y
à une crise agricole en france sans
précédent qu'il ya des agriculteurs qui
sont en train de mourir leurs
exploitations sont en train de mal
heureusement être dans la zone rouge
et on fait quoi pour les agriculteurs et
aux monsieur sapin la croissance ça vous
parle ça serait peut-être bien le sapin
de renouer avec la croissance
sommes le seul pays de ces deux qui ne
le fait pas nous sommes les seuls à
l'être toujours en arrière même matteo
renzi qui avait quand même des résultats
extrêmement compliqué et difficile
aujourd'hui arrive à repartir dans des
situations plus positive et au madame
touraine avec la seule réduction des
déficits de la sécurité sociale grâce au
recul de l'âge et à la réforme des
retraites qui a été entreprise par la
droite
comment peut-on se satisfaire
aujourd'hui d'être dans une situation où
il n'y a pas de retour à l'équilibré de
la branche retraite et au madame causse
où ça en est la construction de
logements
on a baissé de 125 mille le nombre de
logements créés dans notre pays et au
najet vallaud belkacem
vous avez un bilan catastrophique en
matière de rythmes scolaires en matière
également de mise en place du collège
unique serait peut-être bien de vous
attacher à regarder cela et au également
monsieur ayrault l'ipj urbain en parlera
tout à l'heure la france est clairement
aujourd'hui en perte d'influencé en
perte de vitesse dans le monde
monsieur obama fait une tournée en
europe ne vient pas en france et au
monsieur macron le chômage ça vous parle
un million de demandeurs d'emploi en
plus toutes catégories confondues depuis
2012 on a tout essayé contre le chômage
monsieur macron peut-être pas et au
monsieur désiré
monsieur désiré ministre est censé
s'occuper des affaires européennes fait
quoi pour l'europe
ce désir et au monsieur ayrault on
parlera également tout à l'heure ne tape
pas le taffetas l'om c'est la france
elle est où
monsieur c'est qu'elle dit qu'il a du
mal à se faire entendre
ça serait peut-être bien que on avance
un peu et au madame conneries on en est
où avec la rénovation du code du travail
et au monsieur baylet encore la baisse
des dotations a complètement asséché
l'ensemble donné communes qui sont
exemple que fait-on pour leur permettre
de continuer à jouer leur rôle moteur
dans l'ensemble de nos communes et
villages et au monsieur valls ont créé
un rsa jeunes au lieu de permettre aux
jeunes de trouver un emploi au lieu de
renouer avec l'apprentissage au lieu de
mettre en place la promesse de françois
hollande de 500000 apprentis par an
d'ici à 2017 et le gouvernement
notre dame des landes on en est où les
mensonges évidemment toujours
et encore pour terminer et au françois
hollande candidat en campagne président
en campagne qui depuis quelques mois
depuis quatre mois vient de promettre
pas moins de 15 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires
donc on voit tout ça est somme toute
assez étonnant et au la gauche nous on
dit tout simplement
vivement la droite
je vais passer la parole à rio merci je
voudrais pour ma part au nom des
républicains
valérie avant philippe exprimer notre
très vive préoccupation face à ses 15
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires annoncées par le
président de la république depuis quatre
mois
ça n'est pas un détail 15 milliards
d'euros
c'est extrêmement préoccupant compte
tenu de l'état des finances publiques
je rappelle que pour la première fois
cette année la dette publique va
approcher 100 % de la production
nationale et ses 15 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires vont grever le
budget de la nation fragilise nos
finances et fragilise aussi la
dépendance en réalité de la france
puisque bien sur le financement de la
dette nous met dans la main des
créanciers étrangers au moins 4
milliards de dépenses nouvelles pour
2016 avec des primes à l'embauché pour
un coût d'au moins un milliard d'euros
le prolongement d'un an de la mesure de
sur armor tissement pour 400 millions
des mesures relatives à la formation
professionnelle pour 600 millions des
mesures relatives à l'élevage pour 400
millions des allégements de cotisations
agricole pour 500 millions une
augmentation du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires qui dès 2016 coûtera 600
millions des augmentations de
rémunérations des enseignants du
primaire pour 300 millions dès 2016 des
hausses de bourses pour 200 millions et
même il ya quelques jours la création
d'un fonds pour la transition
énergétique de 300 millions
l'énumération peut paraître fastidieuse
mais ce qui l'est plus encore
et ce qui est plus encore pernicieux
c'est le montant total de ses dépenses
nouvelles 4,3 milliards de dépenses
nouvelles au moins pour 2016
s'y ajoutent 1,1 milliard de soutien
annoncées à la jordanie et au liban
il ya quelques jours c'est une annonce
faite par le président de la république
1,1 milliard qui s'ajoute donc aux 4 3
on arrive donc à 5,4 vous ajoutez à cela
pardon d'être un peu long sur l'énoncé
de ces chiffres mais ça me paraît tout à
fait important de faire les additions
3,6 milliards de dépenses nouvelles pour
2017 avec le dégel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires et une hausse de 1,2
point en deux fois donc dès 2016 mais
aussi en février 2017
ce dégel devrait coûter 2,4 milliards
d'euros au budget de l'état
vous y ajoutez des promesses
d'augmentation du régime indemnitaire
des forces de sécurité intérieure pour
650 millions d'euros
l'extension de la garantie jeunes pour
600 millions d'euros en 2010 est la
rémunération des apprentis pour 80
millions d'euros le dispositif unique de
rosny vers celle de la garantie locative
pour 100 millions d'euros une extension
de l'accès à la couverture maladie
universelle pour 20 millions d'euros
et la mise en place d'un plan de
création de classes de bacheliers
professionnels pour 120 millions d'euros
sur cinq ans tout ça dès 2010 est donc 3
6 milliards qui s'ajoutent aux 1,1
précédent et aux 4,3 précédent et vous y
ajoutez pour 2018 à l'horizon 2018 6,6
milliards d'euros pour le rsa jeunes on
voit bien que avec l'addition de ces
promesses coûteuses gouvernement est
désormais engagé dans une démarche de
pré campagne électorale et agit comme si
les comptes de la nation était le compte
de campagne du président de la
république françois hollande
la vérité c'est que la facture de ces
dépenses publiques nouvelles sera
extrêmement difficile à financer
c'est très préoccupant et ça n'est pas
respectée les français que de considérer
qu'à la fin d'un quinquennat il y aurait
en réalité table ouverte pour annoncer
toutes les catégories professionnelles
des dépenses nouvelles ça n'est pas
responsable
ça n'est pas raisonnable ça ne
correspond en rien à l'intérêt national
et nous voulons ici aux républicains
avec beaucoup de préoccupation alerter
les français sur cette dégradation
annoncée des finances publiques y aura
aussi un certain nombre d'initiatives
qui sont prises au parlement il faut que
le gouvernement assume ses
responsabilités nous dénonçons encore
une fois très vivement cette spirale
dépensière qui fragilise notre notre
pays et nous disons avec une certaine
gravité
l'accumulation matin midi et soir des
promesses de dépenses nouvelles
ça n'est pas raisonnable c'est une faute
contre la france que de multiplier de
manière inconsidérée les dépenses
publiques merci beaucoup je vais venir
tout de suite à la question d'actualité
européenne
juste avant permettez moi de faire une
remarque lors quasi professionnel sur le
séminaire gouvernemental qui se passe
dans une faculté de médecine des
facultés de médecine de paris moi même
qui suis enseignant dans une dans cette
faculté de médecine
je considère qu'il est tout à fait
inconvenant que le gouvernement fasse
une opération de communication dans un
lieu qui est un lieu qui n'est pas fait
pour ça qu'ils étaient sérieux on
travaille
on apprend on fait de la recherche et je
pense que les universitaires seront
extrêmement frappé de voir que
gouvernement à cette attitude de kazim
est pris en les utilisant les manipulant
à une opération de pure communication
je ne ferai pas de blagues douteuses sur
le fait que dans une faculté de médecine
en général on trouve soit des étudiants
soient des commandes iraj des patients
qui ne sont pas en très bon état général
le seul patient qu'on trouve sont morts
puisqu'on apprend les disséquer c'est
vous dire que le choix du gouvernement
est douteux dans tous les sens du terme
peut-être que la prochaine fois le
séminaire se fera à lourdes alors je
voulais aborder deux trois questions
d'ordre européenne d'abord pense que
chacun a été frappé par un fait très
simple c'est que ce week-end
donald touche le président du conseil et
qui avait toute légitimité pour le faire
s'est rendu en turquie
accompagné de madame merkel dont on n'a
pas très bien compris à quel titre et
avec quelle légitimité elle allait en
turquie si ce n'est qu'elle espérait
probablement baiser la babouche de
monsieur erdogan
aucun moment la france n'a été associé à
cette démarche
il était inimaginable il ya quelques
années que l'allemagne puisse faire une
telle démarche sans la france la france
l allemagne fonctionnel toujours
ensemble et cette fois ci on voit très
bien que l'allemagne joue seul pourquoi
probablement une certaine volonté de
s'affirmer mais surtout une absence de
la france qui n'est pas capable de
répondre présent et ça se confirme par
le voyage de monsieur obama en europe
qui se rend en grande bretagne et en
allemagne point final là aussi il était
inimaginable il ya quelques années
quelques années qu'un président
américain puisse se rendre en europe
visiter deux grandes capitales que sont
londres et berlin
sans se rendre à paris bien nous
pensions c'était inimaginable ça a été
donc inventé et c'est désormais ce qui
arrive ce qui montre le grand
déclassement de la france dans le
concert des nations
alors sur la question des visas pur que
vous savez que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement réunis au conseil à
quelques semaines honte accepté de
libéraliser les visas pour les
ressortissants turcs nous aux
républicains nous avons considéré que
cet accord était un accord de dupes et
qu'il n'y avait aucune raison de
négocier la question de l'immigration
illégale venant des pays en guerre et la
question des réfugiés avec des
contreparties telles que les visages ça
n'a rien à voir on voit très bien que
c'est un marchandage marchands de tapis
donc nous étions opposés à cet accord
mais il se trouve que les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement dont monsieur
hollande honte à gré cet accord et
monsieur hollande quand il est sorti du
conseil a dit mais ne vous inquiétez pas
pour que les visas soit libéralisé il ya
72 critères à respecter il n'y en a que
35 et en gros avec un gros clin d'oeil
malicieux ça ne se fera pas on voit
depuis ce week-end que monsieur erdogan
m
une pression considérable aux européens
en dix ans les déclarations du type la
question des visas n'est plus négociable
elle est négociable puisque c'est le
droit et l'europe
la firme on est ici c'est un continent
d'état de droit nous avons des règles et
il n'est pas question que pour les beaux
yeux des turcs et la babouche de
monsieur erdogan nous acceptions de
transiger avec les règles qui sont des
expressions d'un démocratie
donc il ya des critères à respecter pour
que les turcs plus bénéficier de la
libéralisation des visas
de l'aveu même de la commission
européenne aujourd'hui ces critères ne
sont pas respectés et donc le jour où
malheureusement la commission européenne
voudra éventuellement violet parlement
européen en disant eh bien il faut quand
même voter sur la proposition
législative je rappelle que pour que les
visas soit libéralisé il ya deux
conditions un vote du parlement européen
et un vote à la majorité qu'on lui
qualifié du conseil nous regarderont
attentivement ce que votre à la france
au conseil et les républicains au
parlement si malheureusement le vote
arrivée sur le bureau du parlement vote
seront évidemment contre parce que nous
considérons que c'est un mauvais accord
deuxième point la question d'autriche et
eu des élections présidentielles en
autriche premier tour avec un résultat
extrêmement impressionnant du candidat
du parti de la liberté le f et au
norbert offer qui a fait un très bon
score car il ya des raisons purement
autrichienne je rappelle que ce parti ce
n'est pas une surprise avait déjà
remporté une élection avec haider qui
avaient trouvé la mort dans des
conditions tragiques il ya une petite
dizaine d'années donc ce n'est pas une
un élément totalement nouveau mais il ya
aussi je crois une analyse que l'on peut
faire kate une analyse politique
l'analyse politique elle est très simple
c'est qu'en autriche il y à un
gouvernement de coalition
la droite et la gauche gouverne ensemble
le parti socialiste est l'équivalent des
républicains gouvernent ensemble en
autriche
voilà ce qui arrive quand on ne
différencie plus clairement ce qu'est la
droite est clairement ce qui est la
gauche voilà ce qui arrive quand il n'ya
plus de colonne vertébrale voilà ce qui
arrive quand on ne sait plus au fond ce
que chacun pense
et bien ce qui arrive dans ces cas là
quand on dit ni droite ni gauche où tout
le monde pareil
eh bien on pousse les extrêmes et on le
voit avec le résultat vaut très cher
le troisième point peut-être l'actualité
c'est la question qui revient sur le
tapis du tt ip le traité fameux traité
transatlantique qui est un traité qui va
couvrir s'il est signé 45 % du commerce
mondial alors qu'en penser premièrement
on n'a pas attendu ce traité pour
commercer avec les états unis
donc il faut arrêter de nous dire oui ça
a c'est la condition du des échanges
commerciaux avec les états unis au
commerce avec les états-unis on n'a pas
de tête et deuxièmement les républicains
n'ont aucune attitude idéologique les
républicains diront très simplement
si l'accord est bon nous le sillon si
l'accord n'est pas bon nous ne signons
pas et aujourd'hui il y à quelques
exemples qui nous font penser que les
records en tous cas n'est pas négociable
mais n'est pas signe abl à l'heure
actuelle prenons l'exemple des marchés
publics les marchés publics sont ouverts
en europe
85% des marchés publics sont ouverts aux
sociétés américaines en europe ce qui
signifie pas qu'ils sont tenues ces
marchés obtenus par les sociétés
américaines les sociétés américaines
peuvent concourir en revanche 32%
simplement des marchés aux états unis
sont ouverts aux entreprises européennes
et donc on voit très bien qu'il ya un
très grand protectionnisme américain qui
est sous tendue par des lois fédérales
le buy america act de 1993 est plus
connu mais il ya une loi qui date de
2009 de la crise économique et haras à 2
ra américaine
oui covering investment act loi de
reprise économique est bien cette loi
limite d'une manière considérable
l'entrée des entreprises européennes et
étrangères aux états unis par exemple en
matière maritime
quand vous construisez un bateau de vous
voulez bénéficier du plan de relance
américain est bien plus de 60% des
éléments du bateau qui servent à
construire le bateau doivent provenir
des états unis d'amérique car le jones
acte qui est un très vieil et gestion
fédérale du des années 30 qui dit que
quand un bateau va d'abord américain un
porc américain il faut qu'il soit
américain construit en amérique avec des
composants américains et 75% de marins
américains n'ont qu'un très grand
protectionnisme fédéral et là dessus il
ya une deuxième couche de
protectionnisme succès des râles avec
des états fédéraux qui considère qu' ils
peuvent édicter des règles qui ne sont
pas celles de l'om sait c'est que la
france l'europe a signé un accord qui
est la mp l'accord sur les marchés
publics qui est un accord omc qui nous
contraint à ouvrir le marché est bien il
ya treize états fédérés qui n'ont pas
signé l'accord à une paix et donc qu'ils
considèrent qu'ils ont le droit d'être
plus protectionnisme est bien quand vous
prenez tout ça en compte vous apercevez
que les américains ne sont pas prêts à
négocier ce point là pour nous c'est
absolument une ligne rouge
les républicains veulent que les marchés
américains soit ouvert et donc monsieur
hollande commence à en faire sa sauce
en réalité on voit très bien qu'il va
l'utiliser dans la campagne électorale
mais nous nous y lisons quoi nous lui
disons que c'est ça fait quatre ans que
les négociations en cours
et qu'est ce qu'il a fait depuis quatre
ans à une réponse à la commission
européenne qui négocie pardon mais le
mandat de négociation a été déjà été
décidés par les états membres par le
conseil
donc la france se réveille très tard
dans cette affaire du ttp est en train
de dire ah oui on nous imposera rien en
réalité
pour des raisons électorales monsieur
hollande veut servir le tti p la raison
c'est que des tp n'est pas bonne
un bon traité aujourd'hui non sa manière
d'être négociées parce que la france
encore une fois été très absente
donc voilà je pourrais vous parler de
bien autre chose si vous souhaitez il ya
un accord google s'est google est
poursuivi pour abus de position
dominante dans la sphère du logiciel
android google impose son moteur de
recherche google chrome dans ses
appareils mobiles
la commission européenne leur a donné 12
semaines à partir de la semaine dernière
pour donner des données les explications
ci sinon ils peuvent être condamnés à
10% de leur chiffre d'affaires ca de
l'ordre de 7 milliards c'est une très
grosse affaire et nous nous félicitons
républicain qu'enfin l'europe montre un
peu les dents face à des grands géants
industriels étrangers qui savent
conquérir des marchés européens sont en
général qu'on bouge le petit doigt
voilà pour les éléments européennes la
semaine